after weeks of speculation concerning
his health North Korea's elusive leader
Kim jong-un has resurfaced that is
according to state-run media who
released pictures of the 36 year old
dictator opening a fertilizer factory
north of the capital ramie innocencio is
in tokyo to put the rumors surrounding
kim's whereabouts to rest
ramie good morning good morning North
Korea's leader Kim jong-un is alive and
is looking very well this after the past
three weeks of speculation crazed
speculation really that he might be
gravely ill in a vegetative state or
even dead two cheering crowds North
Korea's leader Kim jong-un reappeared to
his people and the world very much
living and breathing state-run media
showed him cutting a ribbon at an
opening ceremony of a fertilizer factory
30 miles north of Pyongyang Friday
touring the grounds with aides and
filmed smoking a cigarette
April 11th was the last time Kim was
seen in public meeting his top advisors
but on April 15th
he missed the country's biggest holiday
the birthday of his late grandfather Kim
il-sung North Korea's founder leading
some media outlets to speculate about
his health satellite images later showed
Kim jong-un's train near his private
resort on the country's east coast that
did not prove or disprove Kim was there
or even alive only adding to the mystery
Kim jong-un's disappearance had thrust
talks about possible successors into the
spotlight with his younger sister 31
year old kim yo-jong floated as a prime
candidate North Korea analyst Robert
Carlin unless she has built up some sort
of a power base herself in the in recent
years I don't think she would be if she
became the North's first female leader
she would also presumably control the
country's estimated 30 to 40 nuclear
weapons and any further development of
its intercontinental ballistic missile
program with the continental United
States a possible target now that Kim
Jong hoon is alive this lends some
credibility to the theory out there that
maybe he was just social distancing from
coronavirus just like pretty much
everyone else in the world the bottom
line for North Korea is it is a country
that is very
opaque and any information about it has
to be taken with a lot of skepticism for
CBS this morning Saturday rainy
Inocencio Tokyo